on passe à notre second débat j moins
150 avant le second tour de la
présidentielle tous les 50 jours vous
savez je vous propose un bilan une
analyse des forces en présence ce soit
il sera question du congrès elle est
forcément une semaine de l'ouverture des
votes mais on débat repart la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par les deux chiens
la cinquième vague de covile s'annonce
massive nul doute qu'elle occuperait le
devant de la scène médiatique au cours
des prochains mois et s'invitera dans
les débats de l'élection présidentielle
lorsqu'il entrera en campagne emmanuel
macron sera en pleine gestion de la
crise une position qui jusqu'ici a
plutôt conforté sa cote de popularité
si on regarde sur les vagues précédentes
des études qui ont été réalisées on se
rend compte que cette confiance a été
consolidée tout au long de la crise et
que c'est peut-être d'ailleurs un
emmanuel macron non candidat mais mes
gestionnaire delà de la crise capitaine
en pleine tempête qui lui a permis de
rester sur un socle d'opinions
favorables extrêmement élevé beaucoup
plus que ses prédécesseurs maintenant le
temps de la campagne sera peut-être un
temps différent car la temporalité n'est
plus la même il ne reste plus que cinq
mois avant l'élection présidentielle
s'il faut imposer de nouvelles
restrictions à la population emmanuel
macron ne pourra pas miser sur les
retombées des bénéfices à long terme si
emmanuel macron n'arrive pas à maîtriser
la vague épidémique il en sera tenu pour
responsable directement puisque c'est
l'elysée qui décide de tout il pourra
même y avoir des suites judiciaires ça
peut être une catastrophe majeure pour
lui en termes d'image et en termes
électoraux parce que si on a encore en
mai dans cette situation les français
vont rejeter massivement la personne
qu'ils vont tenir pour responsables et
le responsable ce sera le président
emmanuel macron reste pour l'instant
très bien perçue dans les sondages en
novembre il a gagné quatre points
d'opinions favorables 44% des français
estiment qu'il est un bon président
difficile de dire aujourd'hui si le
retour de la pandémie va affaiblir ou
renforcer cette dynamique de campagne
ont valu tout l'échiquier politique j
moins 150 avant le second tour avec
inviter nos experts sur ce débat
brigitte gaity bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes professeur de sciences politiques à
paris à hauteur de les intellectuels
empêcher ou comment penser dans
l'épreuve 7 aux éditions de l'om et lyon
jean garrigues bonsoir jean historien
professeur à l'université d'orléans
président du comité d'histoire
parlementaire pierre adrien bart au
liban soit directeur des études
politiques chez harris interactive
évidemment laetitia fait pas et rester à
mes côtés je vais commencer par une
petite leçon d'humilité médiatique
évidemment je me mets dans le dans le
lot on va analyser dans cette émission
les chances des uns et des autres leur
dynamique de campagne peut-être faire
quelques pronostics mais on va être
prudent juste rappeler deux exemples
deux précédents la une du jdd on est fin
octobre 2016 qui misent sur alain juppé
voilà at il déjà gagné bref et puis on a
on est allé plus loin cet article du
monde alors le voilà on n'a pas retrouvé
enfin regardez là l'article c'est une
capture pour l'opinion l'élection
présidentielle est déjà joué ça c'est
quand ça c'est en janvier 94 le coeur de
l'article est consacrée à edouard
balladur qui est donné quasi gagnant le
grand favori de l'hiver qui a pas
survécu au printemps chiraquie un bref
voilà petite leçon d'humilité je me mets
dedans en
1995 j'ai dit 94-95 bien su encore
janvier 95 pardon femme lui a pu semer
gta tessin est ok on était très
balladuriens bref donc voilà leçon
d'humilité collective j'en prends ma pas
voilà on va faire évidemment attention
jouez avec vous qu'on commence par
rebondir sur le la crise sanitaire est
ce que pour vous diriez quand même que
pour l'instant c'est encore un atout
dans le jeu de d'emmanuel macron mai et
mais que cette carte maîtresse peut se
transformer en faiblesse brigitte katie
comment vous l'analysez alors pour
l'instant c'est un atout ça l'a été
depuis
maintenant depuis depuis un an en tout
cas ça c'est il ya eu un petit moment
d'incertitude au tout début de la crise
parce qu'il ya eu 7 un peu cette
impréparation les masses que tout ça
mais depuis il me semble que que ça joue
plus tôt pour lui si on peut dire des
choses à on peut évidemment pas
pronostiqué il peut se passer des choses
qu'on n'imagine pas aujourd'hui on vend
des mof mais à ce jour tout laisse
penser que il a acquis une sorte de ice
et bien avant une hauteur
il là il a pris en charge la chance donc
du coup il prend un peu de risques
il a quand même montré que c'était lui
qui décide des bassins gouvernement même
pas ses ministres à peine mais pas son
conseil scientifique est à peine le
conseil de défense dont on ne sait pas
grand chose mais il a pris en charge à
faire donc il se met à vous à mon poste
pour l'instant salua ça a été bénéfique
ne peut pas dire le contraire tout ce
qu'on voit le chiffre que vous donniez
tout à l'heure la les quatre courses 44%
d'opinions favorables hollande en
auraient rêvé là où ils étaient 1 16% à
5 mois de
du premier tour et nicolas sarkozy à 37
pour qu on est plutôt dans une situation
qui semble stabilisée mais les
expériences passées nous ont appris que
tout pouvait se renverser cela dit
aujourd'hui on est obligé de dire ça
jean gardy est-ce que vous pensez que ça
peut se retourner sur le
sur ce dossier sanitaire et donc
s'inverser aussi pour le président ce
qui est sûr c'est que les périodes de
crise conduisent à une
responsabilisation de celui qui était
aux manettes c'était même le cas pendant
pendant les guerres on se souvient de
clemenceau ou du général de gaulle est
donc dans la mesure où il ya une
impression plutôt de maîtrise et
d'autorité ce qu'est ce qui est le cas
pour ce moment en tout cas de la
pandémie c'est positif pour celui qui
est aux manettes comme s'il avait été
plus tôt pour margaret thatcher pendant
la crise des malouines par exemple s'il
y s'il se produisait une catastrophe
sanitaire là effectivement ça pourrait
être très préjudiciable émane de mâcon
dans la mesure où il jouit s'est montré
assez jupitérien dans la crise même très
très autoritaire comme ça ça vient
d'être dit par brigitte d'haïti
moi j'ai tendance à penser que même si
une réussissez pas totalement même si on
pouvait lui reprocher et dieu sait qu'on
me reprocher peut-être a raison de dire
beaucoup de choses pendant cette
pandémie ça serait pas catastrophique
pour lui parce que de toute façon est un
réflexe de légitimité par rapport à
celui qui qui gouvernent celui qui a
donné des épreuves de qu'il est à la
hauteur de la fonction et si vous
regardez moi ça m'a beaucoup frappé des
sondages de légitimité justement est ce
que un tel tel ou tel de ses challengers
est à la hauteur de la fonction
présidentielle
les résultats sont très mauvais pour
marine le pen je crois que là 25% j'aime
beaucoup eric zemmour à 16% et ça c'est
quand même assez révélatrice d'un nerfs
et alors il avait conduit d'ailleurs on
bartoli ses 44 % de popularité bon ça
fait pas une victoire et oral est
évidemment là encore prudence c'est
quand même un socle assez solides et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que si on
rentre un peu dans le détail son sens
qu'il est assez solide même à gauche
exactement et c'est presque le point le
plus intéressant on a l'impression qu'il
ya eu un pivot également en tournée
européenne 2019 une transformation de
cet électorat qui étaient deux tiers de
l'électorat de gauche centre gauche en
2017 qui tout de suite serait devenu un
électorat de centre-droit mais c'est pas
vraiment ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ces niveaux de confiance
sont très élevées à gauche sont
d'ailleurs plus élevées à gauche qu'à
droite alors il ya quand même logique
derrière un peu technique c'est à dire
qu'on a des personnes de gauche qui
continuent à sentir proche de la gauche
proche du ps dans cette grande famille
politique mais qui portent un jugement
positif sur emmanuel macron à droite
c'est un peu différent on a des gens qui
était l air se sentait l air et qui se
reconnaissent aujourd'hui tellement dans
le président de la république qu'au fond
ils ont franchi le pas mais ils se
disent moi mon parti celui dont je me
sens le plus proche quel que soit mon
degré de politisation c'est la
république en marche et donc
mécaniquement ce qui reste j'ai les
républicains sont un peu plus critique
mais ce socle là ce socle de personnes
notamment de gauche qui se disent au
fond il fait le job face à la crise
sanitaire qui l'argument numéro un mais
également dans les réformes comme des
retraites mise de côté évidemment et
enfin certaines réformes sociétales la
pma ou le quoi qu'il en coûte qui est
quand même une mesure qui est pas
franchement marqué libéral de droite ça
tout un écho chez eux et ils se disent
au fond en plus avec une offre en face
on en parlera peut-être oui horaires
normalement à la hauteur au fond
emmanuel macron fait le job il me
convient je peux dire que j'ai confiance
en lui d'ailleurs on va parler de la
gauche juste après cesse ce chapitre
autour des macros et de l'exécutif vous
avez repéré laetitia les éléments de
langage de l'exécutif pour pour se
prévenir d'une certaine façon oui pour
le mois de décembre en fait ça m'a sauté
aux yeux et aux oreilles surtout quand
j'ai entendu gabriel attali hier qui est
un peu
le porte parole directe emmanuel macron
celle porte parole du gouvernement mais
quand on veut savoir à quoi pensent
emmanuel macron et quelle est la
stratégie d' emmanuel macron et le but
emmanuel macron il faut tendre l'oreille
quand gabriel attal parler je vous
proposes to see de l'écouté c'était hier
à la sortie du conseil des ministres
l'enjeu c'est de protéger les français
face à la vague en consolidant nos
acquis et en renforçant notre
organisation de manière à sauver les
fêtes de fin d'année et a traversé
l'hiver le mieux possible voilà donc
éléments de langage sauvés alors
éléments de langage ce sont des phrases
que l'on construit en amont dans une
équipe qui réfléchit à au message à
faire passer est là le message sauvez
les fêtes il est vraiment enfin voila c
on peut pas passer à côté c'est à dire
que il est certainement très efficace
sauver des fêtes et traverser l'hiver
traverser l'hiver ça veut dire qu'on est
après l'hiver ça veut dire qu'on est au
printemps donc on a bien compris comment
se positionne emmanuel macron depuis le
départ de toute façon au dessus de la
mêlée en ce mois de décembre qui
arrivent et qui va être crucial puisque
ça va être juste avant la dinde la dinde
de noël et les discussions n'en mènerez
ne rime pas d'ouvrir c'est pour ça que
tu es autant de meetings qui sont
là il ya un embouteillage parce que tous
les candidats se disent il va falloir
qu'on impact et que on s'invite dans les
discussions des français autour de la
dinde ou des marrons ou que sais-je ou
de la bûche et donc effectivement
emmanuel macron lui bon bien sûr que
c'est aussi la situation sanitaire qui
provoque ce positionnement mais il sait
en tirer profit et se positionne au
dessus de là mais encore une fois est-ce
qu'il restera président jeu comme
mitterrand jusqu'à très tard fin mars
comme mitterrand en 1988 c'est toute la
question et je pense que effectivement
le convient de la situation sanitaire
l'évolution de cette situation va faire
basculer voilà d'un côté ou d'un autre
le président on termine sur le dossier
macron jean garrigues qu'est ce qui peut
faire basculer peut-être le régalien on
a en tête les faits divers la sécurité
qu ont plombé la campagne de lionel
jospin par exemple en 2002 ça ça peut
être un élément oui mais la grande
différence c'est qu'ils emmanuel macron
par son positionnement qui est moins
centré à gauche que l'était celui donné
jospin a peut se permettre deux et c'est
ce qu'il a fait notamment nommant gérald
darmanin de montrer des signes à
l'électorat conservateur qui attend
qu'il attend sur le régalien on lui a
beaucoup reproché d'être insuffisant sur
ce sur ce terrain mais manifestement on
ne peut plus lui reprocher ce que
l'humain jospin se reprocher lui-même
oui j'ai peut-être pas assez traiter ces
questions de sécurité etc on peut dire
que c'est vrai que ces questions de
sécurité el les en bouteille notre
espace notre débat public
la présence des mad d'eric zemmour n'est
pas étrangère mais il n'est pas le seul
mais il n'empêche que on peut pas dire
là que macro et négligé ces questions
pour la première partie de 105 et son
quinquennat sans doute faut il y avait
évidemment d'autres problèmes à régler
là je suis pas sûr que ça pue c'est en
tout cas ce qui est sûr aussi c'est que
il va falloir que sur ce terrain-là
identité sécurité immigration et pendant
sa campagne il donne des signes
tangibles de d'un terrain qu'ils qu'il
donne des choses parce que on voit bien
que ses adversaires notamment les élèves
qui à mon sens peut-être les plus
dangereux pour l'instant est bien allé
vers eux vont beaucoup sur ce terrain de
du régalien donc voilà il ya il ya
quelque chose mais je répète à mon sens
il est moins handicapé que nous les
tellines et j'ose pas par rapport à ces
questions en 2002 c'est certain alors
danser les prisons c'est aussi la neige
et d'ailleurs jacques chirac à l'époque
laissaient aussi lyonnais j'ose pas
aller en première ligne on se souvient
on l'a déjà raconté ici des inondations
dans le nord où jacques chirac et
surtout pas voulu y aller avait laissé
nommé j'ose pas apporté d'engueulades
comment comme mon dieu aujourd'hui alors
dans ces rendez vous tous les cinquante
jours je demande aux invités aux experts
de se mouiller un petit peu pardon mais
donc le premier pronostic il n'est pas
trop difficile enfin peut-être pas
d'ailleurs je vais peut-être surpris par
vos réponses est-ce que vous avez un
doute sur la présence d' emmanuel macron
second tour brigitte katie pour
l'instant nous au cas les choses sont en
train de se mettre en place et donc a
priori non a priori non j'en garde en
cas de catastrophe hausse hormis une
catastrophe sanitaire ou sécuritaires je
ne vois pas de raison pour qu'il ne soit
pas il est à peu près sûr au même niveau
qu on l'attendait donc sur ta 25 qui
touche paul smith et ça parce qu'en fait
ça va être un ticket d'entrée qui va
être très bas donc s'il est à 25
effectivement mathématiquement il doit
être au second tour donne de la marge
sur le ticket dont on imagine
aujourd'hui je suis du camp de jean
garric je suis d'accord il jean
garrigues on n'est jamais à l'abri d'un
rebondissement de dernière minute qui
peut faire tout basculer restons comme
ça si on ressort souvenons nous du
cheminement dans 6 mois vous pourriez
dire j'ai dit ça c'est alors la gauche
la gauche façon puzzle pour reprendre
une une tournure d'un film qui nous a
tous fait rire et qui continue de nous
faire rire de sa petite musique en tête
les tontons flingueurs la gauche at-elle
déjà perdu pour adrien cnas évidemment
la réponse est non pour l' écoute
non l'élection présidentielle n'est pas
perdu pour nous et je regrette qu'à
gauche certains ne semblent agir comme
si c'était déjà perdu et donc moi à
toutes celles et ceux qui ont la vie
toujours plus dures qui ont vécu les
alternances politiques qui n'ont rien
changé à leur quotidien voyez notamment
les trois dernier quinquennat incluant
celui ci lundi maintenant il faut se
réveiller et il faut se regrouper
pierre henri bartoli là il n'y a pas un
candidat de gauche qui dépasse les 10%
d'intentions de vote aujourd'hui vous
diriez quoi un peu de méthode coué
peut-être de la part de 4 aujourd'hui il
ya deux problèmes pour la gauche le
premier problème c'est que la gauche est
divisée donc en plus le les voix se
répartissent entre plusieurs candidats
qui a une conséquence c'est que les
électeurs sont moins prompts que par le
passé a souhaité une candidature unique
quand on tait cette idée là tout le
monde est d'accord à gauche évidemment
mais par contre personne ne veut se
ranger derrière un autre candidat une
colle aux siens ce qui veut dire que
cette solution là où cet axe là n'est
pas vu comme étant particulièrement
salutaire et en plus le total des voix
de gauche est faible on n'arrive pas à
dépasser depuis des mois les 30% et les
faibles pour la gauche donc on a un
potentiel faibles toute une part on a
parlé tout à l'heure d'électeurs de
gauche qui se décroche et s'est
décrochée et qui continuent à voter pour
emmanuel macron dans les enquêtes parce
que au fond ça leur convient et en plus
un émiettement qui fait qu'aucun
n'arrive vraiment à d'une part émergée
et deuxièmement les clés la dynamique
n'est présente chez personne c'est à
dire qu'on est au même niveau par
exemple pour un jean luc mélenchon est
un yannick jadot à peu près et sans
courbe ascendante ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre depuis des semaines et des
semaines et et c'est ça on le rappelle
un qui est intéressant à analyser quand
on regarde les intentions de vote c'est
vraiment les dynamiques c'est pas
prendre un sondage le au jour j c'est
regarder les tendances bouzid d'haïti on
est loin de de la gauche plurielle
époque jospin ou du programme commun
pour au nom très remontés à l'air
lhermitte est en
mode à des querelles d'ego c'est quoi
ces îles sont pas d'accord sur le
programme ils sont pas d'accord sur les
idées comment vous l'analysez alors même
au temps de l'union de la gauche c'est
les gens n'étaient pas d'accord entre le
parti socialiste personne n'était
d'accord mais au fond il y avait un
leadership qui s'étaient constitués en
avance donc c'est une question de
personne en quoi ah non pas une question
de personne question de soutien c'est à
dire que c'est la manière dont les
souffert à mon avis les soutiens ceux là
actuellement il ya personne qui peut
revendiquer derrière lui un appareil
partisan
des forces militantes à par mélenchon
mais qui se situe
peut-être trop à gauche pour certains
qui a fait quelques petits dérapages là
pour le coup lui joue le charisme donc
là vous avez raison il a joué le
personnes et donc du coup ils le payent
aussi quand il fait c et k mais
simplement moi ce que je pense c'est que
là au moment tout à l'heure vous disiez
le le dossier mâcon on peut le faire
mais maintenant on va parler de la
gauche ne peut pas le faire mais parce
qu'au fond tout ça est en relation c'est
une configuration à fait là qu'est en
train de se mettre en place et donc le
fait qu'il y ait un seul candidat dont
on est sûr qu'il peut être au second
tour alors d'aujourd'hui j'appelle mais
bon tout le monde raisonne à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui nous comme les les
concurrentes des métros mâcon donc du
coup mails mâcon n'est pas un adversaire
pour personne parce que il y sera les
adversaires c'est tous les autres prêts
pour ce qu'ils sont une position à 5 10
15 12 au fait j'en sais rien pour pau
pour tout cela il eu ceux sur qui ils
ont intérêt à taper d'un point de vue
stratégique c'est sur ce qu'ils sont
comme eux mais pas sur un passeur
emmanuel macron donc on au pour
reprendre le dossier macron c'est que
lui il est relativement protégé par la
configuration pour l'instant alors que
tous les autres ont exposé à gauche
comme il n'y a pas une construction d'un
leadership préalablement à la com au
début de la campagne eh bien on est dans
une situation où tout le monde doit peut
tenter sa chance et c'est ce qu'ils font
et vous l'avez un peu évoqué ciapa une
tentation du vote utile dès le premier
tour chez d ces électeurs de gauche qui
finalement se disent de toute façon mes
candidats potentiels ils sont tous à -10
donc à quoi ça sert c'est pas tellement
du vote utile non c'est au fond je suis
de centre gauche je considère que manuel
macron contrairement à ce qu'on peut
entendre parfois trop souvent n'est pas
devenu quelqu'un de centre-droit mais
reste quelqu'un bien installé au centre
qui est compatible avec miss des
politiques et pourquoi pas voté pour lui
mais l'autre point c'est presque
l'inversé c'est toute une part de la
gauche un peu dégoûté de l'offre qui lui
a porté avec un souvenir de la fin du
quinquennat hollande qui a quand même
marqué négativement tous ces électeurs
de gauche se dit aujourd'hui au fond à
quoi bon aller voter est-ce qu'ils le
feront à l'avers minutes on verra mais
c'est ses profs par exemple qui ont voté
socialiste depuis des générations qui
aujourd'hui nous dise dans les enquêtes
ce qui est relativement nouveau au fond
à quoi bon au second tour par exemple
quand on teste un maquereau le pen mais
également au premier tour quand on leur
propose l'offre politique actuelle
on sent pas quand même une dynamique
très forte chez eux là la côte
d'adhésion d'anne hidalgo on va évoquer
sa ont fait un focus source doxa
mascaret pour pour public sénat lcp la
presse régionale parmi les sympathisants
de gauche aillent là aussi on est 100
d'une tendance c'est ça ce qui
m'intéresse là c'est le chiffre rouge
d'ailleurs qu'elle est à 38 % avec une
une baisse de 2,5 points
le ps est-il en risque financier avec
avec le niveau de d'intentions de vote
de d'anne hidalgo en écoute olivier faur
qui était ce matin sur france info c'est
pas l'argent qui garantit le résultat
mcfaul l on peut faire des 16 millions
d'euros de dépenses est facile pour cent
et donc vous allez dépenser beaucoup
moins cette fois ci ceux qui disent qu
effectivement c'est une campagne un peu
low cost ont fait un rapport à la
deuxième tout à fait tort mais
passionnel il ya eu une campagne la
nôtre 16 millions il ya eu une campagne
bien plus chiant quand même dépasser les
plafonds autorisés celle de bilma lyon
avec l'ump unis l'une ni l'autre n'ont
gagné enfin danone ont été des campagnes
gagnante eh bien je suggère que on en
tire une leçon ce n'est pas l'argent qui
fait le bonheur ça n'est pas aussi
l'argent qui fait le résultat jean gary
est ce que c'est une campagne qui
dépensent moins parce que via la peur de
ne pas être remboursés si le seuil des
5% atteint exactement ccc c'est un peu
une langue de bois la knu fait olivier
faur parce que historiquement sont
souvent les campagnes qui ont le plus
dépensé qui est qu'ils ont gagné ou en
tout cas quand il nous parle de la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy
c'est nicolas sarkozy au moment où il
justement où il organise ses derniers
meetings ou essayer de rattraper son
retard il a rattrapé effectivement il
est remonté grâce à cette présence
médiatique et grâce à ses meetings donc
l'argent joue aussi un rôle dans les
campagnes on n'est pas aux états unis ou
c ou c majeur mais enfin même en france
c'est pas c'est pas négligeable et
nicolas sarkozy était sur une sur une
tendance haussière c'est ça
qui est un déploiement de moyens mais
pour revenir au socialiste et et à la
gauche dans son ensemble c'est c'est
quand même un phénomène très très
étrange il ya des explications
évidemment mais de penser que cette
gauche qui finalement pouvaient
bénéficier de la conjoncture avec toutes
ces crises crise des gilet jaune crise
pandémique
cette idée qu aujourd'hui il fallait
revenir à l'état interventionniste à
l'état protecteur et c'est au fond que
que les idées de gauche pouvait
reprendre force à la faveur du contexte
économique et sociale et même politique
et bien cette gauche n'arrive pas
justement à capitaliser sur ces sur ce
sur ce contexte pour des tas de raisons
qui tiennent à l'absence de charisme de
deux de ses leaders notamment au fait
que que jean luc mélenchon s'écorner
risée comme on dit dans une attitude qui
n'est plus celle du rassembleur
républicain qu'il était en 2017 il ya
tout un ensemble de raisons mais
fondamentalement c'est très sur le plan
si on prend un peu de recul historique
c'était un moment favorable et que la
gauche puisse émerger et c'est pas du
tout ce qui se produit alors il nous
reste encore deux thèmes on va parler
évidemment du combat et l'air et du
match marine le pen eric zemmour mais
encore un mot sur sur la gauche et
peut-être
aller vers la question des absents sur
des abstentionnistes brigitte gaity je
sais pas si on a plus à gauche mais est
ce que vous avez le sentiment que les
candidats leur parle chercha à les faire
revenir dans dans l'isoloir
dans cinq mois actuellement moi j'ai
plutôt l'impression que les candidats se
parlent entre eux puisque d'aller
chercher d un peu plus que d'aller
chercher les abstentionnistes alors
leurs militants sans doute mais
évidemment c'est un problème est ce que
on a un terrain quand on a nos
politiques à aller chercher des gens qui
n'y sont complètement désintéressé la
politique comment fait-on comment
fait-on il ya eu des tentatives autour
du porte-à-porte souvenez peut-être de
barack obama qui avait été repris par
martine aubry dans sa campagne à lille
enfin voilà essayer d'aller voir les les
gens en direct dans l'interaction etc
puisque les programmes ça ne marche plus
on n'a aucune idée du programme des uns
et des autres d'ailleurs même s'il ya
des publications il y en a qui mettent
des voilà donc le la question
aujourd'hui d'aller vers les
abstentionnistes alors on sait que les
abstentionnistes d'abord se désintéresse
des messages politiques conviennent plus
tôt des couches populaires un peu
abandonné que et donc dû pousser ça
devient très très compliqué de les faire
revenir dans le jeu politique c'est à
dire que comment on leur parle il faut
trouver alors sachant que les gilets
jaunes ont marqué un espèce de
tentatives alternatives dont on ne sait
pas très bien le débouché politique
puisque ça c'est pour l'instant il y en
a pas il y en a pas il y en a pas mais
ça pèse un petit peu peut-être c'est
peut-être ça qui aurait pu peser dans
certaines démarches politiques de se
dire ils sont quand même là quelque part
dans les ronds points
on en a parlé dans récemment ce qui en
reste ce qu'il en reste c'est peut-être
la crainte et oui elle a brûlé pour lui
pour notamment pour le pour l'exécutif
c'est possible c'est possible que ce que
ce soit ça mais en tout cas il ya cette
espèce de
2,2 possibilité d'aller voir d'aller
voir la deux je sais plus qui leur a
construit un abri bus à grenoble ou pour
à 2 pourrait pour être
débloqué dix mille dix mille euros pour
les blessures infligées voilà semble
aussi bien entendu mais c'est
intéressant dans la démarche allez un
petit pronostic au tour d'anne hidalgo
est ce qu'elle sera encore candidate au
mois de janvier qu'est ce que vous en
dites pierre-adrien bartoli non
impossible de dire pour l'instant donc
vous pour la santé on peut savoir on
peut pas avoir de réponse elle incarne
courants historiques mais c est qu à sa
place mais elle est un niveau faible et
sans dynamique jean garrigues année je
suis j'ai la même opinion ses traits ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'un rapport de
force s'est inversé en faveur de deux
décante des candidats écologistes donc
il y aura en tout cas pas une situation
à la 2017 ou le candidat écologiste va
se désister pour le candidat socialiste
donc elle est quand même sur le fil du
rasoir des 5 6% n'est pas du tout
certain qu'elle aille au bout ce qui est
frappant c'est que pour reprendre que
vous disiez madame elle est en tournée à
dalgo depuis lundi elle est en tournée
dans toute la france elle a quitté paris
elle est allée à la rencontre des
français avec sur la thématique du
pouvoir d'achat et donc qui rejoint
complètement une des luttes des gilet
jaune or qui a entendu autour de 7 à
parler d' anne hidalgo depuis lundi ça
vraiment donc je ne sais pas s'il ya un
bashing des médias en tout cas elle
imprime ni dans les médias ni dans
l'opinion publique et ça quand on est
invisible et qu'on est candidate à
l'élection présidentielle ne se fait pas
à ma question et ce sera encore là en
janvier
non non ben voilà il faut prendre
presque voisine d'haïti en janvier
franchement vous prenez pas de risques
mais vous avez le droit elle et on passe
au parti elle est à l air et il est au
bord de l'implosion dans la dernière
ligne droite avant la désignation de son
ou de sa candidate les militants vont
voter la semaine prochaine lors du
congrès alexandre pousse à vous pouvez
nous nous rejoindre alors y en a un qui
fait bouger les lignes c'est eric ciotti
on a décidé de faire un focus sur eric
ciotti car c'est l'un des outsideurs
dans ce congrès les républicains mais il
pourrait créer la surprise en se
qualifiant au second tour de cette
primaire fermée en tout cas la question
elle est posée par les observateurs de
cette compétition interne eric ciotti on
l'a senti on l'a senti très à l'aise
durant les débats télévisés de cette
primaire fermée les républicains et
s'est distingué car il défend sa ligne
d'une droite dure notamment sur
l'immigration il veut instaurer le droit
du sang pour obtenir la nationalité
française il n'a pas peur de reprendre
la thèse du grand emplacement et en cas
de duel emmanuel macron avec zemmour au
second tour il le dit clairement il
votera eric zemmour une ligne de droite
radicale qui peut plaire aux militants
les républicains qui composent le
collège électoral de ce congrès et en
tout cas avec cette île sans une
dynamique en sa faveur on va l'écouter
il était mardi et bien devant le groupe
l'est républicain au sénat je sens une
dynamique qui s'installe à vue ce matin
même ici dans ce dans le groupe
tous les parlementaires étaient étaient
présents beaucoup de monde à mes
réunions beaucoup d'adhésions après le
premier débat et je crois que tentons
par le vrai quand on parle de sincérité
moi j'ai toujours été fidèle à ma
famille fidèle à mes convictions j'ai
toujours porté le message d'une droite
forte qui assume son positionnement et
bien on marque des points en tout cas
avec ce style est tellement confiant
qu'il a déjà annoncé qui sera son
premier ministre s'il est élu président
de la république et ce sera laurent
wauquiez l'actuel président de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes ancien patron du
parti des républicains est partisan de
la même ligne d'une droite décomplexée
laurent wauquiez il ne soutient aucun
candidat officiellement durant ce
congrès les républicains mais on le dit
en coulisse proche de michel barnier
mais vu la physionomie des débats
télévisés il pourrait aussi pousser en
coulisses la candidature d'eric ciotti
fait cette dynamique ciotti a même
poussé vers la sortie le président de la
région paca renaud muselier et oui avec
un hymne broglio comme la droite on a le
secret mardi soir renaud muselier
apporté son soutien à xavier bertrand
dans ce congrès les républicains mais
coup de théâtre et xavier bertrand
refuse ce soutien de renaud muselier je
ne peux en accepter les termes dit il
ces attaques donc les attaques de renaud
muselier contre eric ciotti et contre
david lisnard le nouveau président des
maires de france sont inacceptables en
effet renaud muselier estimé
publiquement qu eric ciotti et est le
faux nez de l'extrême droite dans ce
congrès les républicains et que sa
famille politique avait un problème de
positionnement vis-à-vis de l'extrême
droite alors certains cadres des
républicains sont montés au créneau pour
protéger avec ce ticket pour enfoncer
renaud muselier on va écouter bruno
retailleau le président du groupe plr au
sénat le problème de positionnement
c'est pour lui même puisque au moment
des régionales il a prêté la main au
gouvernement à la macro 10 pour
déstabiliser sa propre famille politique
il savait était d'ailleurs expliqué en
toutes lettres dans un article paru dans
un grand journal du dimanche donc déjà à
l'époque cette ligne ce flou là il
apportait je pense que la politique ce
sont des convictions c'est la clarté
quand on n'est pas clair ou quand on se
sent pas à l'aise dans une famille
politique il vaut mieux la quitter voilà
renaud muselier en a pris pour son grade
alors la conclusion de cet épisode
certains la résume en une phrase eric
ciotti tulle m où tu quittes le parti
alexandre pouces à 7 cette analyse
pierre adrien bartoli c'est compliqué de
sonder autour autour de la
du coup mme dallaire pourquoi parce que
c'est sans presque 150 1148 1000g 6 par
la jet set où les belges eux les noter
146 mille et quelques inscrits qui vont
pouvoir voter
et vous n'avez pas forcément les
éléments parce que l'air vous les donne
pas pour pouvoir les sondés c'est ça oui
parce qu'il ya une question aussi
d'égalité ça on peut pas retrouver ces
personnes là comme on avait pu retrouver
par certains moyens les électeurs des
primaires ouvertes qu'il a pour le coup
à 15 millions de personnes dans des
enquêtes on peut les avoir là on parle
de très très très peu de personnes donc
aucun moyen de faire des sondages et
aucun moyen de savoir quelles sont les
tendances au sein du parti et puis
deuxième en jeu autant dans une primaire
ouverte on peut essayer de choisir la
personne qui est la plus proche de notre
ligne politique ou qui incarnerait le
mieux le candidat et ensuite le
président dans une primaire fermée qui
envoyait un congrès interne en pe aussi
choisir quelqu'un en fonction de son
affiliation sa proximité un dirigeant de
section locale a de l'intérêt personnel
très fort ce qui n'existe pas sur une
élection ouverte et ça ça peut peser
très fort le jour de l'élection
continuez trop leur bulletin
électronique dans l'urne
la côte d'adhésion des candidats à
l'investiture l air d un dernier élément
qu'on a trouvé xavier bertrand 65% c'est
chez les sympathisants de droite or
rassemblement national xavier bertrand
en hausse de 5 points valérie pécresse
57% en baisse de 6 points michel barnier
à 51% en hausse de 4 points eric ciotti
dont on parlait à l'instant 30 2% +1
point et philippe juvin 23% il n'avait
pas été testée dans le
sondage précédent je reste avec vous car
adrien bartoli sur sur la sociologie ou
même l'origine géographique
j'imagine que l air doit avoir ces
informations donc quand on prend les
nouveaux inscrits jeu bien avant tout
cas mais s'ils viennent massivement
d'île de france peut-être que ça pèse
pour valérie pécresse quoi on voit c'est
plus compliqué que sa force et c'est un
peu plus compliqué que ça notamment
parce qu'en fait on a d'une part
l'adhésion l'arrêt adhésion des gens qui
étaient sortis notamment avec valérie
pécresse vers libres avec la manufacture
de bertrand qui ont pu ré adhérer juste
avant le congrès et puis quand on prend
une carte des du poids par département
on a évidemment les corps aux
fédérations qui pèse très lourd c'est à
dire les alpes maritimes c'est à dire
paris c'est à dire les divines qui sont
sur représentés et c'est bien normal
cela on trouve ses électeurs la question
qui va être intéressante c'est la
différence sociologiquement possible
politiquement entre les adhérents et les
sympathisants
et puis si on élargit encore plus les
électeurs potentiels et c'est là que les
choses vont être un peu un peu
intéressant c'est qu'on se mentant les
militants nous dire oui effectivement
eric ciotti fait une campagne qui nous
intéresse il parle de thématiques qui
nous intéresse mais quand on le teste en
tant que candidat représentant ait l'air
au premier tour de la présidentielle il
fait 5 % parce qu'au fond ils arrivent à
garder qu'un cas un petit quart des
électeurs fillon parce que certes il
peut parler à un choeur militants très
fort peut-être on le verra lors du
congrès quand on aura les résultats mais
est-ce qui parle à ce bassin plus large
d'électeurs potentiels pour l'instant
pas tant que ça ça c'est vraiment très
intéressant 148 1862 là ils étaient deux
chiffres est-ce que j'en gagne c'est un
succès en soi ou alors si on fait un peu
d'histoire politique c'est votre c'est
votre spécialité finalement ça reste
très peu par rapport à d'autres périodes
notamment dans l'histoire de la droite
les partis de la droite ça reste très
peu même si la france n'a pas une
tradition partisane donc ça jamais été
des des chiffres colossaux mais pour en
revenir juste peu
en aparté pour pour eric ciotti et il
est un peu dans la situation de benoît
monde du côté de la gauche en 2016 lors
de la primaire de 2016 benoît hamon
c'est celui qui plaisait au noyau du
parti mais qui ne pouvait pas être un
candidat de rassemblement y compris même
dès le premier tour donc c'était
vraiment pas et ça c'est à mon sens
c'est un peu la position d'eric ciotti
même s'il a été le meilleur dans les
dents manifestement dans l'est dans les
débats et le plus clair en fallait dans
la série la ligne la plus dure c'est
qu'ils alignent parce qu'il a la ligne
la plus dure maintenant je pense que les
beaucoup semble-t-il va se jouer sur la
capacité des chaque candidat a comme on
dit à attirer à eux de nouveaux
adhérents dans leurs fédérations je
disais et en double on dit beaucoup que
michel barnier s'est pas mal débrouillé
de ce côté-là il a derrière lui laurent
wauquiez mais pour l'instant c'est vrai
que le jeu est assez est assez ouvert et
aussi une petite musique paix créée
sienne depuis quelques temps précieux ce
qui est sûr c'est que celui des musiques
et toutes les rumeurs par dianna agron
récente et nourrissent par deux ans et
qui on va prendre quand même parler
d'eux
du duel le pen zemmour dans un instant
même si on a déjà consacré une émission
récemment là dessus donc je voudrais
vous entendre quand même brigitte
d'haïti sur le la bataille des idées
finalement c'est peut-être ça qu'il faut
retenir de de cette pré campagne c'est
hier les idées de droite ou
d'extrême-droite diront certains et
elles sont omniprésentes en cette
pré-campagne est-ce que c'est déjà pas
une victoire est ce que c'est pas déjà
une victoire en soi pour la droite ou
l'extrême je suis pas bien sûr que la
bataille des idées soient complètement
lancé mais je moi ce que je me demande
en entendant les débats au sein de la
lettre c'est acquis par l'oedt il est
donc acquis par le tilt pécresse et
c'est pourquoi ils sont tous sur ces sur
la l'immigration la sécurité pourquoi
ils vont tous justement c'est une
question que je serais presque envie de
vous poser c'est à dire c'est quand même
pas beaucoup 150000 personnes six ans un
petit peu de de staff autour d'eux ils
peuvent savoir un peu qui qui va voter
donc pourquoi il ya une espèce de
droitisation je ne sais pas si c'est de
lectorat mais pour le coup de ce présumé
ou anticipés par les candidats de ceux
qui vont être les adhérents donc on a
quelque chose de très bizarre et qui va
être problématique
une fois le candidat
sorti alors ça c'est ciotti ça ne doit
pas trop de problèmes mais si ces
quelques ados ça serait ça serait moins
pire comment revenir sont des thèmes
beaucoup plus classique de la droite
bracke libérale économique et à oulhaça
apparaît vraiment très très se déforme
extrêmement radical qui rien simple on
revient comme enfin le candidat pour
revenir s'il veut et se repositionner un
bo centre sens mais un premier jalon
celui qui se rappellera s'il va relancer
la surenchère actuellement celle-ci si
celui qui sortent c'est celui qui est le
plus mal placé pour faire ça et là c'est
sacrément après mon livre je trouve
effectivement j'ai fait imprévisible et
donc vous du mal à répondre à ma
question vous placez candidat ou
candidate elle est au 5 décembre jean
garrigues commence avec vous le favori
très vite le favori pour moi c'était 7
et xavier bertrand parce que précisément
lui se positionne en challenger de demel
mâcon c'est le seul
qu'on installe un stade poignée de main
interminables les yeux dans les yeux il
s'en est pas trop mal tiré il s'est pas
trop mal tirés des débats il a un
positionnement social et de proximité
qui peut qui peut lui permettre de
plaire à une partie de l'électorat
traditionnel d'ailleurs y compris de
l'ump la famille gaulliste donc ça peut
ça peut être lui mais franchement moi
pour l'instant je serais incapable de
dire qui va sortir donc un petit plus
pour débattre en les
bertrand oui mais ça va dépendre
justement ces 150 me tarde de la
sociologie un problème est là problème
spir adrien bartoli impossible à dire
notamment parce qu'il ya cet enjeu
d'intérêt personnel et non politique qui
va entrer en compte aller moi je mets un
billet sur valérie pécresse allons-y le
pen zemmour il nous reste une minute
trente ça passe trop vite cette émission
elle est passionnante j'ai juste vous
demander un pronostique eric zemmour
sous les 10% en avril oui ou non
pierre-adrien bartoli baisse là ça fait
deux semaines on voit qu attendant c'est
une tendance baissière il a encore loin
des 10% c'est lundi en avril et il a un
électorat pour l'instant très volatile
qui s'est vite agréger autour de lui
mais qui tuent aussi très vite repartir
et nous c'est ça qu'on va mesurer dans
les prochains mois dans quelle mesure
qui va arriver à les solidifier autour
de lui voir élargir pour aller plus loin
dans quelle mesure au contraire d'autres
mais on l'a vu là avec les débats et
l'air vont venir sur ces thèmes et
capter une part de ses électeurs ça sera
le débat jean d'haïti c'est un plafond
de verre où c'est peut-être simplement
un palier avant de repartir à la hausse
c'est vrai que c'est un plafond mais ça
dépend aussi du combat ça dépend de lui
et pas que depuis excusé moi ça dépend
des autres là s'ils se mettent toujours
sur son sur ces terrains ils risquent de
2,2 se maintenir voire de progresser
encore un peu parce que là il tient
l'agenda il a tenu l'agenda de du
congrès l'air donc tout le monde se
positionne par rapport à lui donc de
fait il a une position il n'a pas besoin
de faire grand chose j'ai eu ça dépendra
de la capacité justement du candidat ait
l'air à aller récupérer une partie de
l'électorat qui l'a été chipé par
warzone l'identité du candidat et leurs
dépenses
comme je viens version c'est drôle parce
qu'il ya un mois et demi on
inverse c'est lui qui a rebattu les
cartes mais comme j'étais leur la
crédibilité d'eric zemmour me semble
quand même très faible la
présidentialité d'eric zemmour me semble
très faible il ya eu beaucoup de
provocation quand même qu'ils ne passent
pas du côté de cet électorat qui devrait
être son électorat potentiel donc moi je
crois plutôt au plateau au plafond de
verre est donc oui on peut dire que la
stratégie de l'éclat l'éclat permanent
finit par la teinte c'est ici à ces
risques oui c'est la stratégie de donald
trump mais eric zemmour départ donald
trump donc ce que je voulais 10 en avril
ou pas aucune idée bon faire sinon merci
à tous et merci de vous prêter au jeu
des pronostics est jamais simple pour
pour un expert je vous dis à lundi sur
public sénat